>> Greg: DON'T AGREE WITH THE
DEMOCRATS?
YOU MIGHT BE A BIG OLD IDIOT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN LASHING OUT AT
HE PROTESTERS WHO CALLED HIS
POLICIES SOCIALISM.
>> I LOVE THOSE SIGNS WHEN I
CAME IN, SOCIALISM.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
WHAT IDIOTS.
SOCIALISM.
NO ONE EVER DOUBTS AT ME WHEN I
SAY SOMETIMES, I SAY ALL THAT I
MEAN.
>> Greg: THAT MADE NO SENSE.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST LIBERALS IN
AMERICA THINKS MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO VOTED FOR
REPUBLICANS ARE STUPID.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY'RE
TREATED LIKE THEY'RE A BUNCH OF
DUMMIES.
THEY'RE NOT IDIOTS.
OK, NOW GRANTED, THERE'S 330
MILLION IN THE COUNTRY, MAYBE A
GOOD 80 TO 90 MILLION AREN'T
VERY BRIGHT.
NO OFFENSE TO THOSE WATCHING WHO
AREN'T BRIGHT.
YOU'RE WATCHING MSNBC SO I'LL
MAKE THE ASSUMPTION THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Greg: THAT'S INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, JESSE, THIS STUFF
DOESN'T BOTHER ME ANYMORE.
I MEAN, IF WE GET UPSET ABOUT
THIS, THEN WE'RE THE SNOW FLAKES
THAT WE'VE BEEN, YOU KNOW,
MAKING FUN OF FOREVER.
IT'S LIKE IF YOU GOT -- I MEAN,
WHAT DID TRUMP SAY TO PROTESTERS
WHEN HE CAME IN?
KNOCK THEM OUT!
AND WE FOUND THAT MAGICAL.
>> Jesse: WE DID AND STILL DO.
THEY ARE RIGHT THAT THEY USED
THE WRONG WORD.
THERE ARE A LOT OF IDIOTS OUT
THERE.
I DON'T CALL THEM THAT.
I CALL THEM OBLIVIOUS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE SMART
PEOPLE, THEY'RE NOT JUST PAYING
ANY ATTENTION.
WHEN I USED TO GO OUT ON THE
STREET, WE USED TO FIND OUT THEY
WEREN'T PAYING ANY ATTENTION AT
ALL.
THAT'S OK.
IF YOU ASK PEOPLE ABOUT TAX
POLICY, HEALTH CARE POLICY, KIND
OF THAT STUFF, THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO KNOW THE DETAILS BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T REALLY AFFECT THEM THE
WAY CERTAIN THINGS DO.
INFLATION AND CRIME AFFECT
EVERYBODY.
AND YOU CAN BE OBLIVIOUS TO
EVERYTHING IN WASHINGTON EXCEPT
INFLATION AND CRIME BECAUSE
EVERYBODY SEES PRICES GOING UP
AND FEAR TRAVELS FAST.
YOU KNOW WHEN CRIME IS RISING.
SAME THING WITH TERRORISM.
PEOPLE FELT SCARED.
YOU CAN'T DISMISS IT AND SAY
YOU'RE BEING MISINFORMED BY
RUSSIAN BOTS OR THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IS JIVING YOU.
YOU HAVE TO MEET THEM WHERE THEY
ARE, AND SAY I FEEL IT, TOO.
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
YOU CAN'T JUST BE A DETACHED
SNOB AND SAY YOU'RE AN IDIOT.
>> Greg: SHE'S RIGHT THERE.
SHE'S NOT A DETACHED SNOB.
>> Jessica: HE SAID HE LIKED ME.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING.
BOTH SIDES DO THE THING WHERE
THEY CALL THE OTHER SIDE STUPID.
BUT I THINK JESSE IS RIGHT.
THERE'S NO -- IT'S NOT ABOUT
INTELLIGENCE AT ALL.
IT'S ABOUT CONFIRMATION BIAS,
RIGHT, IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE IN
SOMETHING, IT'S HARD FOR YOU TO
CHANGE YOUR MIND.
ISN'T THAT THE TRUTH?
THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT THIS IS.
>> Jessica: EVEN CONFRONTED WITH
FACTS ABOUT IT, PEOPLE WILL
STILL SAY NO, IT'S THIS.
>> Greg: WE HAVE A LOT OF THAT
WITH YOU WHEN WE TRY TO CONFRONT
YOU.
>> Jessica: SO KIND YOU KEEP
INVITING ME BACK.
CONFIRMATION BIAS IS HUGEMENT
PARTISANSHIP IS OFF THE CHARTS.
IT USED TO BE THAT PEOPLE WERE
QUITE FLEXIBLE AND WILLING TO
LISTEN TO BOTH SIDES ABOUT IT.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY THAT IT WORKS
ANYMORE.
GOING TO THAT, YOU KNOW, BIDEN
SAYING THOSE IDIOTS, HE GETS
SPIKES IN APPROVAL WHEN HE'S
HIMSELF.
REMEMBER WHEN HE CALLED THAT GUY
A DOGFACED PONY SOLDIER OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
PEOPLE LIKE UNVARNISHED JOE
BIDEN.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
EXAGGERATIONS OF THE ECONOMY OR
WHATEVER IT IS.
BUT WHEN HE HAS AN INSTINCTIVE
RESPONSE, WHEN HE MALARKEYS,
WHATEVER IT IS, IT REMINDS THEM
OF THIS GUY THAT THEY'VE KNOWN
FOR DECADES WHO THEY THINK IS A
REALLY GOOD GUY.
AND THAT HE'S ABLE TO GET THINGS
DONE IN A BIPARTISAN WAY WHICH,
FRANKLY HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO.
>> Greg: I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
IF THAT BEHAVIOR WAS EXPRESSED
WHEN HE DEALT WITH THE LEFT.
BUT HE'S COMPLETELY BEEN RUN
OVER BY THE HARDCORE
PROGRESSIVES IN YOUR PARTY.
I MEAN, HE SEEMS TOUGH THERE BUT
HE'S A WIMP, JUDGE.
>> Jeanine: HE IS A WIMP.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO GO PAST
THAT WORD, OK, IF THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR.
HERE'S THE TRUTH.
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN MISLEADING.
IN FACT, HE'S BEEN LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND THE, I
BELIEVE IT'S A FEW OTHER CNN
HAVE BASICALLY SAID JOE BIDEN
HAS BEEN LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND THOSE ARE DEMOCRAT LEANING
TELEVISION AND PRINT.
YOU KNOW, HE'S LYING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT, YOU KNOW, HE'S BEEN
TELLING US THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
GAS HIKES ARE THEIR FAULT AND
THE CRIME IS A RIGHT WING
CONSPIRACY AND NOBODY NEEDS TO
WORRY ABOUT IT.
HE ALLEGES THAT HE REDUCED THE
FEDERAL DEFICIT BY $1 TRILLION,
400 BILLION OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
AND NO ONE HAS REDUCED IT,
ACCORDING TO THE FACT FINDERS.
POLITICO HAS FOUND THAT HE HAS
LIED.
HE CLAIMS, AND HE'S TRYING TO
TAKE CREDIT FOR THE INCREASE IN
SOCIAL SECURITY THAT IS REALLY A
RESULT OF A BILL THAT WAS PASSED
INTO LAW 40 OR 50 YEARS AGO THAT
SAYS SOCIAL SECURITY HAS TO KEEP
PACE WITH INFLATION.
THE MAN IS LYING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
SO LET'S NOT SUGAR COAT IT AND
SAY, YOU KNOW, IT JUST, YOU
KNOW, SWEET JOE AND, YOU KNOW,
JUST A LITTLE MALARKEY.
CUTE STUFF.
HE'S OUT AND OUT LYING.
>> Greg: DANA, WHAT DO YOU MAKE?
>> Dana: I WANTED TO ADD
SOMETHING TO WHAT JESSE SAID
ABOUT THOSE TWO ISSUES, CRIME
AND INFLATION REALLY AFFECTED
EVERYBODY.
BUT SO DID COVID.
AND FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER, FOR EXAMPLE, IF
YOU'RE A RESTAURANT OWNER, MAYBE
YOU LOST YOUR ABILITY TO MAKE A
LIVING FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS,
ALSO FOR PARENTS WHO WATCHED
WHAT HAPPENED NOT ONLY THEIR
KIDS WERE OUT OF SCHOOL BUT WHEN
THEY GET BACK TO SCHOOL, THEIR
TEST SCORES ARE DOWN AND THEY'VE
FOUND OUT MORE ABOUT THE WOKE
EDUCATION SO THOSE TWO THINGS
ARE HAPPENING.
OTHER THING IS STACEY ABRAMS
DOWN IN GEORGIA, SHE IS LIKELY
TO LOSE TO BRIAN KEMP TOMORROW.
SHE CONTINUES TO SAY THAT VOTER
SUPPRESSION IS THE ISSUE.
AND THAT SHE SAID THAT HER
VOTERS ARE BEING FED
MISINFORMATION.
I ACTUALLY THINK -- IF PEOPLE
ARE ABLE TO MAKE UP THEIR OWN
MINDS AND SHE HASN'T BEEN AS
PERSUASIVE.
2.5 MILLION PEOPLE IN GEORGIA
VOTED EARLY AND THAT'S 500,000
MORE THAN IN 2018 AT THIS TIME.
SO I THINK HER VOTER SUPPRESSION
NONSENSE IS WEARING THIN.
>> Greg: THAT IT IS.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S NOT WEARING
THIN?
YOUR INCITEFUL COMMENTARY.
AHEA